all right people this is it our last
show at newsmax it's january 14th 2022
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message live from boca raton
florida after today i finally move into
my new house we get the makeshift studio
going while we build out the big studio
and i just want to thank everyone here
at newsmax for hooking us up they made
it a very very seamless easy
week for us and i hope you've enjoyed me
back in studio i've been very excited to
be back in studio and i've been
wandering around boca raton and a lot of
old people saying they like me it's
pretty great everything's good and we
got a big show for you today before i
get to that of course as you know we are
streaming on rumble on youtube on blaze
tv do a little subscribe thing tap a
notification bell whatever it is that
you do if you could just make sure
you're doing the right thing that would
be appreciated and we're going very
heavy today on joe biden you may know
joe biden he is the man pretending to be
the president of the united states and
he gave a big
speech yesterday updating us all on
kovid and i actually watch the full
speech because sometimes i don't have
time i have a life much like you guys i
don't have time to watch all of the
things that these people are doing and i
just see clips you see things on twitter
or maybe you're on facebook for whatever
reason or wherever else you get clips
but yesterday i was actually
right after we finished the show here at
newsmax there was a truck waiting
outside i was on america's newsroom with
dana perino my friend and bill hemmer
and uh we i thought we were going to get
preempted because biden started giving
this speech so i ended up watching the
entire biden speech and we're going to
show you like five or six clips from
this thing because lo di lori it was
a doozy so we're going very heavy on joe
biden up top uh then the second story
which is actually great news related to
kovid uh the supreme court struck down
the osha mandate for companies over a
hundred employees which is absolutely
fantastic that was led by my friends
over at the daily wire so we'll talk
about that and then i thought a nice way
to end this week and to sort of pave the
road
forward
as i get to the new home studio in
florida would be a throwback clip you
know we've tried to do these every now
and again i want to start doing them a
little bit more but we found a really
really great clip from ronald reagan
talking about freedom and communism and
really what it's all about so we're
going to throw to that so three stories
for you today so let's get right to it
joe biden gave a big speech yesterday he
reads these things off teleprompters not
particularly well but i want to give the
devil as due and i want to show you as
much of the speech as possible so we've
got a couple clips he started with this
now i don't like to uh
you know uh
outline the next steps we're taking
against uh i'd like to outline the next
steps are taken against over on the the
omicron variant
all right all right so you can see he
got off to i would say a rocky start but
then he started to hit his stride
you can find the nearest testing sites
for you
by googling covid
test near me google covid
test
near me
and to help uh lead our federal testing
program
i've talked i've i've taught i've excuse
me i've tapped uh dr tom
i hope i pronounced it
and angel
angles me
is that right okay so you can see things
continued to go well and then he decided
to tell us that he'd like more
censorship if you haven't gotten
vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america's ever faced
ah
the inspiration never stops with this
guy i want to reread the quote there
that was the key part of the whole thing
and that very passionate plea that joe
made i make a special appeal to social
media companies and media outlets please
deal with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows it
has to stop now putting aside
i don't know what he's talking about
with shows
what he means by that is
censor things that we don't like even
though we've got everything wrong
basically from the beginning whether it
was the efficacy of vaccines or the
usefulness of masks or whether lockdowns
made sense or anything else as i
mentioned on the show yesterday you know
there's some of us who i guess deserve a
little pat on the back
that kind of roughly got some of this
stuff right and didn't lose our minds
over the last two years and a lot of
people that you would have called
conspiracy theorists two years ago you
know vaccine mandates are coming these
things don't seem to be working why is
it that the pharmaceutical companies are
not legally responsible for what happens
like a whole bunch of stuff now we're
allowed to talk about it oh maybe it did
leak out of the lab in wuhan maybe it
did have something to do with some of
the research that fauci and the nih were
funding we kind of couldn't talk about
that now we kind of can maybe i'll be
booted who the hell knows
but the scary part about that joking
aside is when biden is saying to these
companies please deal with
misinformation and disinformation
that is basically as close
as the government can come to overriding
the first amendment without us having
some sort of constitutional crisis like
he's saying hey i'm the head of the
government here right
and i'm asking you guys to do censorship
i know i can't tell you guys to do
censorship because then that might be a
problem
but i'm asking you guys to do it and
then the question is what other levers
of power that we don't know about can
they apply
to force facebook
or maybe not even force to hint gently
to facebook at board meetings or
wherever else oh yeah you should get rid
of this stuff it goes against the
approved narrative by the way this is
the same administration that i'm sure
you guys remember this clip we played it
many times a couple of months back where
jen saki
said that they
the administration flags certain content
on social media for the social media
companies the big tech companies to deal
with okay so this is what this
government wants it wants to make sure
that social media companies ban and
censor whatever they don't like which of
course they label misinformation and
disinformation now when they put out
misinformation and disinformation that's
all good that's a proved narrative man
but you know when we do it we got
problems but uh it continued with biden
he uh he lied a lot during this speech
here's some lies
i've been i've been saying that as we
remain in this pandemic this is a
pandemic in the unvaccinated
and i mean by this right now both
vaccinated and unvaccinated people are
testing positive
but what happens after that could not be
more different
as a result
they're crowding their hospitals leaving
little room for anyone else who might
have a heart attack or an injury in an
automobile accident or any injury at all
and yes the unvaccinated are dying from
covet 19. okay there's so much [ __ ]
in that very short clip first off show
me someone show me an article point me
to a person that was rejected from a
hospital when they had a heart attack or
a car accident simply has not happened
it has not happened and if you can point
me to it by the way i'll gladly retweet
it i will mention it on the show next
week and by the way that if you can find
one instance of it that actually
wouldn't prove anything because he's
trying to make it sound like this is
happening all over the place these
unvaccinated people are overwhelming
hospitals where are the videos of the
overwhelming hospitals anywhere in the
world where where are they why have we
never seen the images
did these people not have phones they
unvaccinated walking around without
phones um so he's lying about that okay
that's just a lie also he's changing his
language on this pandemic of the
unvaccinated because a whole bunch of us
called [ __ ] on him you know a week
or so ago when he kept saying this is a
pandemic of the unvaccinated and then
what happened over the last couple of
weeks well then everybody got coveted
and it didn't matter whether you were
unvaccinated vaccinated 18 ways
boosted or anything else and then
suddenly it seemed very fraudulent that
he was saying it's a pandemic of the
unvaccinated also by the way notice when
he says this okay so here i'll even give
him some credit maybe it is true i'll
i'll we can do a little research and i
would recommend that you do your own
maybe it is true that the unvaccinated
especially of a certain age are going to
hospitals more often but notice he
doesn't mention the age he doesn't
mention how many people and even if that
is true he still never talks about
personal choice he still never talks
about your ability to make decisions for
your for yourself right whatever's right
for you and your family and everything
else but it's just
endless
fear just endless fear and if you think
all of that wasn't bad enough
here is how the whole speech ended
i'll stop here so we can get to the
briefing started
thank you for taking the time
mr president message for vaccinated
americans who are wondering why they
should continue to restrict their
activities given your health officials
say most americans will get coveted at
some point
folks we'll talk about that later
why should americans trust your
administration
[Music]
i mean that is seriously depressing and
scary stuff and if that was donald trump
sitting there confused with the papers
he's shuffling things around he's
ignoring people he's looking for someone
to help him he's got the blank stare
in his face i mean if that was donald
trump they'd be screaming about the 25th
amendment right they'd be talking about
impeachment and everything else it's
like
this guy is just not in charge i'm sorry
i wish he was i wish the president of
the united states was cognitively
capable right i wish this guy even if i
didn't agree with him like the guy's
still flying the plane you want the
pilot to roughly know what they're doing
so that was deeply depressing to end
that thing it's sad and it's scary and
it's weird and it's like
man are we ever going to talk about it
and the scandal around it really is the
non-scandal because we all know it but
we're not talking about the scandal
because mainstream doesn't make it
happen but we were watching that and it
made me think we could probably find
something fun to do with that
i'll stop here so we can get to the
briefing started
thank you for taking the time
[Music]
folks we'll talk about that later come
on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
lordy lordy all right well then biden's
day did not end there then he had to
give a talk a little later to the press
you know every now and again they let
him sort of wander out to the press
corps or suddenly someone sticks a mic
in his face and you could see all his
handlers like no he's going to do it
again
but he just walks up to them and he says
things and now he does this new thing
where he's always faking anger well the
other thing that was happening yesterday
of course uh beyond just the the covid
stuff uh is now there's all this
discussion about voting rights laws and
what the scary republicans are doing by
making sure that you have to have an id
to vote or say be a citizen to vote and
somehow this is subverting our democracy
so gideon so biden talked to the media
about that
we can come back and try it a second
time
we missed this time
we missed this time
and the state legislative bodies
continue to change the law not as to who
can vote but who gets to count the vote
count the vote
count the vote
it's about election subversion
not just whether or not people get to
vote
who
counts the vote
that's what this about that's what makes
this so different than anything else
we've ever done i don't know that we get
it done but i know one thing as long as
i have a breath in me as long as i'm in
the white house as long as i'm engaged
at all i'm going to be fighting to
change the way these legislatures have
moved me thank you
adjust the meds people okay sake in the
morning when he's having his coffee put
an extra pill in or split a pill or
something the fake anger or whatever's
going on on there the dysregulated anger
everything else and of course what he's
saying is a lie these republican states
that have passed some of these laws have
passed things like voter id
they've passed things like you got to be
legal to vote unlike what's happening
now in new york city that we covered a
couple days ago please someone i plea
i have a plea to you people show me
someone who is in the united states
legally who's here who cannot vote
do you think that anyone any respectful
decent roughly mainstream person would
stop them from voting i want every
citizen who's here legally who's legally
allowed to vote to be able to vote but
you should have to show an id you should
have to legally be here you know we can
have a couple rules around it when he's
talking about it's not who votes it's
who counts the votes first off that's an
old uh nazi
i think that was an old nazi uh meme
originally that concept or maybe that
was stalin it might have even been
stalin but but yes it is who counts the
votes and they're making sure it's going
to be all of their people and they want
to make sure that they can do ballot
harvesting and all of these other crazy
things and by the way that is one of the
reasons that i left california for the
free state of florida because i could
not deal with the nonsense i mentioned
this many times but when you mail in
your ballot
for that recall election when you mailed
it in back in january
sorry back in september that was of
course
no matter which way you folded
the ballot you could either see yes on
recall or you could see larry elder's
name if you just held it up to light
like that's what they want that is the
stuff
stalin by the way i was right on that it
was a stalin quote those who cast the
votes decide nothing those who count the
votes decide everything so joe biden
possibly inadvertently is quoting joseph
stalin there you go all right uh despite
all the nonsense with joe there was a
whole bunch of good news yesterday and i
know it's a little hard to find the good
news you gotta wade through stuff and
you gotta kind of really look for it
sometimes but there really was some
great news yesterday the supreme court
blocked the biden administration's osha
vaccine mandate we've got some info on
that from the daily wire on thursday the
supreme court blocked a biden
administration mandate that would have
forced private businesses with at least
100 employees to require workers to be
vaccinated against covet 19 or submit to
regular testing okay so this has been
one of the big ones that everybody's
been fighting about as you know the
daily wire themselves led by jeremy
boring and ben shapiro and the other
guys
they were one of the companies fighting
this harmeet dillon my friend who's been
on the show she was one of the leading
lawyers on the case and this is this is
great news it got all the way up to the
supreme court and in my humble
estimation the supreme court did make
the right decision now i can't tell you
that it was all perfect yesterday
because the other decision that the
supreme court made was that the mandate
on health care workers would stand and
believe it or not brett kavanaugh
was the deciding vote on that he voted
saying that it would stand for health
care workers now i i'm not going to sit
here and pretend that i am a
constitutional scholar i have some
pretty pretty good knowledge of some of
this stuff it seems a little bit weird
i'm going to try to read it later when
i'm in the car i'll read
his commentary on it it seems a little
odd to me if you say oh it is
unconstitutional
for private companies to force people to
be vaccinated that but it is
constitutional for health care companies
to do it it's like i don't know how that
fits into the constitution that
depending on the type of work that you
do now there may be some minutia and
details in there that we can we can go
through so we'll see a little bit more
about that but in essence
this idea that these companies with at
least 100 employees are not going to be
forced to do anything they don't want to
do which by the way kicks the choice
back to the individual right it makes
you make a choice for yourself i would
like to be vaccinated i will go to work
or perhaps i can talk to my boss about
working from home if other people aren't
vaccinated and i'm worried about that
that's the messiness of freedom it's the
beauty of freedom rather than top-down
government you must do this to work here
i don't have 100 employees but i know i
know in my bones i have no right whether
i have 10 employees or 100 employees to
say to people who work for me who are
not my slaves they work for me in an
open and honest free exchange i have no
right to say them you must get injected
with this thing to work for me so this
was good this was this was really really
good and it's just another marker and i
know it's hard to see guys as i said
before you got to kind of look through
the brush but it's just another marker
that things are turning a little bit the
biden approval rating that we talked
about yesterday at 33 percent the glenn
younkin win in virginia which is a big
hit on critical race theory the fact
that people are going
showing up to stores and seeing the
supply chain stuff and going oh maybe
that does have something to do with the
policies of this government or when we
see 9.7
inflation and you go oh again maybe this
has something to do with the policies
like people are waking up when you see
people going over the last couple weeks
hey i didn't get vaccinated i got
covered that guy did get vaccinated he
got covered we all kind of it all kind
of shook out the same maybe i'm allowed
to ask some questions
yeah you know what it's still america
and you're still allowed to ask some
questions and speaking of america i
thought we would end this week with a
throwback clip we found this really
fantastic ronald reagan's speech this is
a video of ronald reagan warning us of
government overreach and appeasement
take a look
no government ever voluntarily reduces
itself in size so government programs
once launched never disappear
actually a government bureau is the
nearest thing to eternal life we'll ever
see on this earth
what does it mean whether you hold the
deed
to the or the title to your business or
property if the government holds the
power of life and death over that
business or property and such machinery
already exists
the government can find some charge to
bring against any concern it chooses to
prosecute
every businessman has his own tale of
harassment
somewhere a perversion has taken place
our natural unalienable rights are now
considered to be a dispensation of
government
and freedom has never been so fragile so
close to slipping from our grasp as it
is at this moment
now let's set the record straight
there's no argument over the choice
between peace and war but there's only
one guaranteed way you can have peace
and you can have it in the next second
surrender
admittedly there's a risk in any course
we follow other than this but every
lesson of history tells us
that the greater risk lies in
appeasement and this is the specter our
well-meaning liberal friends refuse to
face that their policy of accommodation
is appeasement
and it gives no choice between peace and
war only between fight or surrender if
we continue to accommodate continue to
back and retreat
eventually we have to face the final
demand the ultimatum and what then
you and i know and do not believe that
life is so dear and peace so sweet has
to be purchased at the price of chains
and slavery
if nothing in life is worth dying for
when did this begin
just in the face of this enemy
or should moses have told the children
of israel to live in slavery under the
pharaohs
should christ have refused the cross
should the patriots at concord bridge
have thrown down their guns and refused
to fire the shot heard round the world
the martyrs of history were not fools
and our honored dead who gave their
lives to stop the advance of the nazis
didn't die in vain
where then is the road to peace
well it's a simple answer after all
you and i
have the courage to say to our enemies
there is a price we will not pay there
is a point beyond which they must not
advance
man chills up my spine and i'm sure i'm
not only speaking for myself that sort
of clarity that sort of honesty that
sort of
decency from a good man who didn't want
to rule your life just wanted to create
the conditions so you could rule it
yourself i mean there's a couple
incredible quotes there that i think
ring ring pretty freaking true today
what does it mean whether you hold the
deed or title to your business or
property if the government
holds the power of life and death over
that business or property does that
sound familiar over the last couple
years does that sound familiar
and by appeasement what he's talking
about
is that we keep giving we keep giving oh
no no if you just stay at home if you
just wear a mask if you just get
injected if you just stay on the
government dole because they're not
letting you go to work just more and
more and more and it's just kind of
small and we're just going to appease
and appease in peace and appeasement
doesn't work right ask neville
chamberlain about that hitler guy and
that's sort of where we're all at at the
moment we've appeased we've played this
thing was crazy two years ago we didn't
know what was happening as i said
yesterday it's like i grant everybody
that first month of covid we all get a
pass we all got to pass it was so crazy
did a few people were there a few voices
out there like no if we start with
lockdowns and masks and everything else
this will go to a horrible place yes
i think i roughly warned about that
doesn't matter it doesn't matter anymore
everyone gets a pass at the beginning
but now it's time no more appeasement no
more appeasement
make a decision no more surrender do you
want to live free or do you not want to
live freely like that's the choice right
now and those words i mean send that
clip around man you can cut me out of it
send that clip around and and
this is a time tested battle that we're
in right now when he talks about the
children of israel in egypt when he
talks about christ on the cross this
thing has been fought before and it will
be fought again and what side are you on
well i know what side i'm on and i have
nothing better to do than save the world
and i really mean that and i'm going to
be doing it from the free state of
florida so on that note uh i once again
want to thank all the folks over at
newsmax who hooked us up this week
i'm off to close on the house get our
makeshift studio going and we'll be back
on monday officially at our new time
live streaming at 11 a.m pacific no
sorry that's what we used to do 11 a.m
eastern
8 a.m pacific
my full interview with rand paul who
smacked down anthony fauci is up on
youtube and rumble right now and if you
want to communicate with me directly if
you want to get ad-free videos if you
want to talk to other viewers etc etc go
to reubenreport.locals.com
uh i've got a crazy weekend ahead of me
of moving stuff in and you know just
getting life in order i hope you have a
good one and i'll see you on monday
thanks everybody
you